hey 42 here you know that feeling when
all you want to do
is dive into the dark forbidding ocean
off an island in the middle of nowhere
and look for sharks no me neither
but for kirakiro arataki that
was a good day out in 1986 this resident
of yanugunijima
a tiny sliver of land off the coast of
taiwan in the east china sea
went scuba diving to the south of the
island looking for the best place to
observe
the hammerhead sharks known to
congregate there in large numbers
but what he found instead was something
much much more interesting peering into
the depths
he glimpsed the towering mass of stone
rising almost 30 meters from the ocean
floor
but it wasn't the monolith size that
caught our attacki's attention
no it was the fact that it appeared
to be man-made he rushed back to land
and returned a short while later
with a team of scientists headed by
professor masaki kimura a marine
geologist from the nearby university of
ryoku's
initially kimura believed the formation
could be natural but after the first
dive
he was convinced he was looking at the
remains
of a giant stepped pyramid part of an
unknown city from antiquity in
subsequent dives a geologist
mapped the full 45 000 square meters of
the monolith
identifying remnants of what he believed
were once a castle
five temples an entrance way
roads drainage channels public meeting
spaces and a stadium he also claimed to
have found
carvings in the rock that proved human
occupation
words in some unknown language as well
as crude carvings of animals and faces
kimura estimated the structure to have
been about 10
000 years old dating it back to a time
when it still would have been above
water that was towards the end of the
last ice age
during the slow four that took place
between 19 000
and 6 000 years ago a period during
which global sea levels rose by about
120 meters
of course if it really was 10 000 years
old
the yanaguni monument as aratake's
discovery
is now known would have been constructed
a full 5 000 years before
the egyptians built the pyramids which
led
kimura to an even more astonishing
conclusion
that the monument off the coast of
yanaguni island
was the last remains of the fabled
continent
of mu a word of caution to any budding
archaeologists out there
if you're trying to build professional
credibility it might be best to avoid
basing any of your theories on the
existence of a magical kingdom that
supposedly sank into the sea that kind
of thing doesn't tend to come across
well in job interviews
anyway in case you've never heard of it
the land of mu
is basically atlantis but in the pacific
ocean
instead of the atlantic the myth began
in the 19th century with archaeologist
augustus la planchon
he was known for his studies of mayor
ruins in mexico
he claims to have translated an ancient
mayor text
called the popple vu which he said
proved the mayor civilization predated
those of greece and egypt he also said
the book revealed the existence
of an even older continent that he
connected with the legend of atlantis
he called the lost continent mu and
named it as the source of the main and
egyptian civilizations
but it was his successor a man by the
name of james churchwood
he would take things to a whole new
level
[Music]
according to churchwood whilst he was a
soldier stationed in india
he earned the trust of a temple priest
who showed him ancient clay tablets
inscribed with a forgotten language once
he'd managed to decipher the tablets
churchwood realized they contained
information
about the lost continent of mu which had
once sustained an advanced civilization
called the narcol bigger than south
america
moo was apparently home to the garden of
eden
more than 64 million people and was the
birthplace of the great civilizations
of egypt greece central america
india burma and even easter island
sadly the entire five thousand by three
thousand mile land mass
disappeared one night after a series of
catastrophic earthquakes
and volcanic eruptions caused a
continent to disintegrate
and sink beneath the waves most
inconvenient
beyond the fact that it's about a place
called moo described
in an extinct language written on
tablets that nobody has set eyes on
except the guy who's telling the story
the myth
is hard to believe because it has
absolutely no scientific evidence to
support it
the theory of plate tectonics which has
been well established since the 1970s
pretty much rules out the possibility of
lost
continents and even if one had been
submerged
by an incomprehensible natural disaster
we should still be able to find it today
zealandia for example is a massive piece
of continental crust
that broke away from the supercontinent
gondwanaland
around 80 million years ago it
eventually sank
but pieces of the landmass still stick
out
above the surface of the ocean as
islands
we call the biggest of these new zealand
zealandia is almost big enough to be
considered a continent in fact there are
campaigns underway to have it recognized
as such
and it's pretty easy to spot using
modern technology
so it's fair to assume that mu which was
apparently more than seven times bigger
than zealandia
wouldn't be hard to find even if it
really had been swallowed up by the
pacific ocean
given all these facts it's not hard to
see why the scientific community
didn't exactly jump at professor
kumara's claims
that the yanaguni monument might be the
last pieces of the lost land of mu
that didn't however mean there wasn't
something unique about this submerged
formation
in 1997 the first expedition to yanaguni
was organized by a japanese businessman
with the aim of uncovering the
underwater structure's
secrets he invited a few camera crews
and the team of international
archaeology
experts that included john anthony west
graham hancock and robert shock
well i say experts
this wasn't exactly a crew of nobel
prize-winning scientists
west and hancock are prolific writers in
what is
widely regarded as pseudo-archaeology
and whilst their theories of ancient
civilizations have enjoyed broad
popularity
neither is credited with any formal
archaeological education
shock meanwhile is actually an associate
professor
of natural sciences at boston university
with degrees in geology and geophysics
from yale
but despite his academic record he's
best known for a fringe theory he
developed with john anthony west
regarding the great sphinx of giza the
pair
claim the sphinx shows evidence of water
erosion due to rain
which they believe makes the statue much
older than is conventionally believed
instead of being about 4500 years old
and built for kafra
a pharaoh of egypt's fourth dynasty the
sphinx would be
five thousand to ten thousand years old
and the work of a much older and more
advanced civilization
this is a controversial view to put it
lightly
shock is also known for his belief that
all the pyramids across the globe
may have originated from a central
civilization
that existed in sunderland which i
thought was a small city in the
northeast of england
but is apparently a continent-sized
stretch of land in southeast asia
between six thousand and eight thousand
years ago
since this is long before the agreed
date that civilization
began on earth the theory hasn't been
very popular amongst fellow
archaeologists
fairly or unfairly these unconventional
beliefs
have also seen shock branded with
accusations of pseudoscience
so it was a bit of a blow when he
visited the yanaguni monument in 1997
and concluded it was most likely a
natural rock formation
when the pseudoscientists think you're
talking nonsense
you're usually in trouble the monolith
is cut from one
massive piece of stone it isn't made of
blocks or bricks
as is more common with man-made
structures
but it does from some angles look
remarkably similar to a ziggurat
a stepped temple tower common in
mesopotamia
between 4000 and 2500 years ago
like the yanaguni example ziggurats had
no internal chambers
and were usually square or rectangular
with multiple steps and levels
a famous example being the ziggurats
terraces that formed the foundation
of the hanging gardens of babylon which
are one of the seven wonders
of the ancient world if they actually
existed that is
nobody seems completely sure on that
point amongst the most mysterious
characteristics of the yanaguni
structure
are the dramatically clean lines of the
steps and corners
which simply look too perfect to not be
man-made
but shock says the shapes aren't as
regular as many people claim
and that some misleading camera work is
to blame for the confusion
from some angles yanaguni really does
look like some kind of
sunken ancient palace but from others it
looks like a big pile of rocks on the
ocean floor
he also maintains the clear cuts can be
attributed
to natural geological forces and
if you've ever visited the giants
causeway in northern ireland
you'll know random geological forces can
get pretty creative when they put their
mind to it
the rock formation at yanaguni is made
from sandstone and mudstone
which are known to fracture in very
clean straight lines and
similar patterns of erosion can be found
not too far away on land
in the form of wide sharp cut terraces
according to shock the large number of
earthquakes experienced in the region
might have amplified the effect of
brakes along cracks and fissures in the
rock
and the incredibly strong ocean currents
around the monolith
could have accounted for the exaggerated
erosion patterns
including the marks on the rocks kimura
believed to be in
ancient writing or pictures another blow
to kimura's theory came
when a submerged cave system was found
near the monument
as you probably know stalactites are
formed by the action of water dripping
from the ceiling of the cave
leaving behind microscopic deposits
which accumulate
over millennia which means stalactites
can only form in caves that are above
ground
so if you find stalactites in a cave
system
under the ocean they can be dated
to give you a precise point in history
when the cave was last on dry land
and when stalactites in the submerged
cave systems near the yanaguni monument
were dated
they were found to be far younger than
kimura's original age for the monument
of 10 000 years not that kimura was
particularly bothered with this
revelation
when faced with evidence that didn't
quite fit his narrative
he simply tweeted his story suggesting
a massive earthquake about 2000 years
ago
could have caused the land to fracture
tilt and then slide into the sea
he also suggests these dates will
correspond to the
proposed time of yamatai an ancient
country that predates japan
but the location of which has been
debated hotly for decades
by japanese scholars and archaeologists
because hey he wasn't going to miss the
opportunity to throw yet another mystery
into the mix
whether or not yonaguni really is
man-made
it seems safe to assume the last time it
was on land
local humans would have been drawn to it
from uluru in australia to the oddly
shaped sandstone butts of monument
valley
we humans have always been fascinated by
unusual stone monoliths
which is why some people have suggested
our ancestors almost certainly used
yanaguni in one way or another
admittedly the site doesn't exhibit the
kind of archaeological
detail found at other submerged sites
like
atletian in israel this ancient
neolithic village off the coast of the
mediterranean sea
may not have been a major civilization
but it has been carbon dated to between
8 300 and 8 900 years old
and contains features like remains of
rectangular houses
a stone circle with mega lifts a five
metre deep
well human skeletons arrowheads and
axes i'm not saying it's a competition
but
none of these signs of entrenched human
settlement have been found at yanaguni
of course this may well be due to the
intense ocean activity at yanaguni
created by the competing forces of the
pacific ocean
and the east china sea as well as the
regular typhoons and
massive waves found there in fact the
largest tsunami ever recorded
a 40-meter high monster hit yanaguni in
1771.
so is the yonaguni monolith the remains
of an
ancient and advanced civilization just a
bunch of weird rocks on the ocean floor
or some kind of combination of the two
the truth is nobody really knows for
sure
and thanks to the relentless savagery of
the ocean
even if an ancient civilization did
build yanaguni
there's unlikely to be enough evidence
left to prove it
admittedly the natural geological causes
hypothesis
is probably favorable at this point but
as
is the case with most of the world's
great mysteries
at the end of the day people will still
believe whatever they want to believe
but it's safe to say kimura and his
supporters
are going to need to conjure up some
more convincing evidence that the
structure
is man-made before the wider scientific
community will be willing to believe the
former
not that it matters because as is
usually the case with these things
people will see what they want to see so
big block of eroded sandstone
or the last remains of a mystical
ancient paradise
claimed by the ocean's depths you decide
thanks for watching you can get your
hands on my book stick a flag in it
over on amazon or on audible links to
both in the description below
thank you